oi gente então quando as pessoas me
perguntam de onde eu venho
geralmente a resposta causa espanto e às
vezes vira motivo de piada como a voz e
escutaram eu sou pesquisadora na
universidade canadense mas eu fui pro
canadá da finlândia da finlândia
tailândia eu fui da nova zelândia da
nova zelândia eu fui da irlanda para a
irlanda foi da inglaterra mas eu nasci e
fui criada aqui no brasil eu me formei
na federal do paraná e incidente no
ensino médio professora de ensino médio
por oito anos antes de sair do brasil
meu pai tem descendência germânica
minha mãe tem descendência indígena e
meus filhos viajam sem passaporte
português
então essa história internacional acabou
influenciando o meu objeto de pesquisa
que é a cidadania global
eu estudo o imaginário da educação
dentro da ideologia do desenvolvimento
internacional pra dar pra vocês um pouco
da idéia do que eu faço lá fora eu vou
começar com uma analogia
eu vou pedir pra vocês imaginarem um a
uma colheita de milho vocês conseguem
imaginar uma colheita de milho na frente
de vocês têm servido descascado
eu vou perguntar se o que vocês
imaginaram aparece com essa fotografia
normalmente as pessoas imaginam o milho
amarelo esses meninos coloridos golpe
foi tirada no peru
essas medidas são verdadeiras mas eu uso
a idéia do milho amarelo que é
geralmente as pessoas imaginam como
analogia para a nossa incapacidade de
imaginar milhões de cores diferentes
eu uso é o melhor ela também como
metáfora para falar sobre o conhecimento
reproduzido na escolarização nas escolas
que é uma forma de saber que não sabe
que não sabe que sim mas limitadas em
reconhecer os seus limites
então essa forma de saber é reproduzida
na escola produz uma história única uma
narrativa única de progresso de
desenvolvimento e de evolução da manhã
então o meu trabalho e educação é fazer
uma análise desse histórico e percebi
começar a pensar uma educação com uma
escolarização pode ser imaginada de uma
forma diferente
eu me foco principalmente mas ler aqui
as criadas por essa forma de saber que
dividem a humanidade entre aqueles que
lideram o desenvolvimento progresso e
evolução e aqueles que impactou o
progresso desenvolvimento e evolução da
humanidade
então essa imaginação da da humanidade
em dois tampos certas pessoas nascem e
percebem que elas são seres humanos
completos normais e inteligentes e
outras acabam sendo a percebidas e se
percebe também como seres humanos
incompletos anormais e menos humanos e
menos inteligentes então na educação
isso se repete não só a não só aqui no
brasil na inglaterra onde eu trabalhei
mas em vários lugares no mundo inteiro
eo meu trabalho então perceber como é
que isso está sendo reproduzido e como é
que isso pode ser pensada de uma forma
diferente
no âmbito internacional essa hierarquia
de desenvolvimento elas se reproduz
baseada no mito de que desenvolvimento é
reproduzida é produzido a partir do
conhecimento da capacidade das pessoas
então esse mito faz com que a gente
perceba quem nasce num país desenvolvido
como mais inteligente e quem mais num
país mais pobre como menos inteligente
então um país emergente como o brasil é
um país onde as pessoas estão começando
a ficar inteligente dentro dessa visão
de mundo e repassam as ea ameaça aqueles
que foram inteligentes até agora e essa
é uma produção sistêmica quer dizer que
em massa em países e em país pobre
acredita na mesma coisa eu vou dar um
exemplo pra vocês mas para dar esse
exemplo eu preciso que vocês a se
engajar em uma visualização comigo
imaginem que vocês são alunos do ensino
médio numa escola européia e hoje o
governo mandou pra vocês um questionário
a ser respondido por todos os alunos
na sua cidade é um questionário sobre
desenvolvimento e apego primeira
pergunta do questionário é a seguinte
por que o governo do seu país desse país
europeu deve ajudar os países mais
pobres
e aqui estão as suas possibilidades de
resposta sem marcar um x
porque se a gente não ajudar a não
ajudarem as pessoas desses países vêm
tirar nossos empregos e desequilibrar
nossa economia as pessoas desse país se
envolvem em conflitos violentos ea gente
acaba tendo que intervir
as pessoas desses países para doenças
que nos afetam as pessoas desses países
vão continuar a destruir o meio ambiente
a gente não entendeu ficaria mais
perigoso tirar férias nestes países
então esse questionário foi usado na
inglaterra de 1994 a 2007 e os alunos
que respondem a esse questionário
aprendem a associar à pobreza os países
mais pobres com ignorância violência
destruição lixo doenças e servidão e ao
mesmo tempo ao fazer isso o outro eles
aprendem a se identificar com a cara com
as características opostas de
inteligência benevolência merecimento
honestidade e limpeza e liderança
e essas características não todo acabam
justificando a sua superioridade o
direito de intervenção de tentar arrumar
e ajudar o outro
como tanto também como a a sua despesa
do seu direito ao seu privilégio então
que é é então é percebido como a
segurança deles é essa essa divisão
justifica o direito de se defender a
segurança frente à ameaça que o outro
representante hierarquias é uma
hierarquia que depende com a
superioridade depende de um outro que
precisa ser percebido como inferior não
tem como ter superioridade sem o outro
que é inferior
e essa sujeira que se reproduzem não só
na inglaterra não só na europa na
américa do norte como aqui também em
vários contextos de forma extremamente
semelhantes ea minha barraquinha parte
de pesquisa e educação então é a tentar
perceber
se isso pode ser modificado com isso é
produzida através da educação e como
isso pode ser modificado
eu vou dar um outro exemplo normalmente
quando eu vou a trabalhar com
professores nesses países há em diversos
países não só na europa na américa do
norte mas também na américa latina eu
sempre faço uma dinâmica com os
professores e pergunto pra trás pra eles
a me dizerem me responderem como é que
eles p matriz percebe nos seus contextos
sociais como é que eles percebem a
sociedade ideal e como se chega de a
abin
normalmente quando eu pergunto sobre o
contexto ideal não só aqui na américa
latina mas os outros países também
a resposta é relacionada à violência
pobreza o desemprego abuso de drogas
afeta poluição e mais e mais a gente tem
a depressão e ansiedade
dentro desse contexto quando eu pergunto
sobre a sociedade ideal a resposta
normalmente relação da paz famílias
felizes e etnias nacionalidade de mãos
dadas campus verde cheio de flores e
quando eu pergunto como se passa de aa a
b
a resposta é invariavelmente a
construção do conhecimento através da
educação
então dentro dessa visão de mundo se
percebe o problema como ignorância e
conhecimento como algo que vai levar a
raiva a a abortar essa ignorância e
levar gente da sociedade ideal
e aí que o mito do milho amarelo aparece
né
a gente percebe que o milan roma e
amarela acaba sendo a solução para os
problemas são causados pelo próprio irã
amarelo
então é muito mais difícil perguntar que
tipo de conhecimento leva relações que
causam os problemas que a gente
identificou e como esse próprio
conhecimento limita a um agente formulo
os problemas e como a gente pode
imaginar as respostas
em outras palavras a gente acaba é
tentando responder eu a abordar os
problemas que a gente tem os dando mesmo
paradigma de conhecimento que gerou
esses problemas
portanto a resposta às perguntas que a
gente faz a educação no meu grupo de
pesquisa por exemplo se relacionam a que
tipo de conhecimento pode nos levar a
perceber o limite
é de conhecimento que recebemos de
herança histórica
será que a educação pode ser usada para
se pensar genuinamente diferente
que tipo de educação pode nos ajudar a
encarar a complexidade à incerteza por
ali da desigualdade de forma que a gente
possa cometer erros novos e evitar os
recorrentes
então em relação à ataque
a gente continua a buscar soluções para
dilma de conhecimento responsável pelos
problemas que a gente quer resolver isso
nos leva a repetir os mesmos erros
passados e em linguagem e conteúdos
diferentes
então a minha resposta às perguntas que
eu coloquei a minha resposta à tentativa
é de que não adianta votar naquilo que a
gente não imagina como extensão do
próprio conhecimento
a gente precisa focar naquilo que a
gente não consegue imaginar aquilo que a
gente não sabe que a gente não sabe
e para isso a gente precisa contemplar a
beirada limite do nosso conhecimento e
isso a escola moderna não ensina pra
começar a contemplar beirada limite do
nosso conhecimento é necessário olhar
para a produção do conhecimento em si e
para começar essa conversa eu
normalmente uso a metáfora de um bolo no
topo do bolo está o que a gente fala que
a gente pensa eo que a gente faz a gente
é levada perceber que essa pensar que
essas o que a gente fala que a gente
pensa que a gente faz são coisas que
estão interligadas e que são coerentes
mas não funciona bem assim
então o que a gente fala principais está
ligado à nossa história única e pessoal
o que a gente aprende nas nossas
famílias nossos contextos não só o que é
consciente mas também foi inconsciente
nossos medos nossos traumas e nossas
paixões mas a nossa história única
pessoal não é só unipessoal também ela
está ligada na última chamada do bolo
que é e são as referências coletiva
sobre a realidade sobre o conhecimento
que a gente era através da linguagem
através das nossas culturas e através da
nossa história
as escolhas feitas na base do bolo
determinam o que vai acontecer nas
camadas ea cima do bolo e são escolhas
que determina o que é desejável as
perguntas que podem ser feitas há como
se procurar as respostas o que pode ser
dito eo que pode ser negada
como são escolhas sempre existem as
escolhas que não foram feitas mas se o
nosso conhecimento se percebe como
ilimitado e único
a gente vai ter mesmo dificuldade enorme
e imaginar milhões de cores diferentes
mas aqui a questão não é de substituir o
milho amarelo pelo milho verde primeiro
e azul e rosa ou por vários níveis mas é
perceber e cada meio tem seu histórico e
que a diferença é absolutamente
necessária para a nossa sobrevivência
a gente precisa de forma diferente de
existir no planeta principalmente quando
a forma dominante pode não ser
sustentável e levar à destruição
então dentro desse contexto é importante
perceber de onde vem esse milho amarelo
e porque ele ficou dominante como é que
ele domina a nossa imaginação e para
isso é importante pensar no pensamento
cartesiano que faz as divisões entre
mente e corpo em razão e emoção cultura
e natureza que determina uma história de
progresso e desenvolvimento baseada na
ciência na tecnologia e que pensa na
segurança como felicidade com a busca da
felicidade constante
então nesse contexto é preciso
problematiza a racionalidade totalizante
e coloca o homem no centro do mundo e
que demanda soluções simples
empreendedoras e que possam ser
comunicados em 15 minutos
nesse contexto pessoas escolarizadas
como eu tem um agente foi educada e
socializado no meio do mar amarelo
a gente tem uma dificuldade enorme de
lidar com a complexidade quando valência
com a pluralidade conflito com a
incerteza com a desigualdade e isso é
porque o milho amarelo continua agitando
uma narrativa única de progresso
desenvolvimento e de humanidade
isso pode ser observado também no sonho
brasileiro e ser adquirido com a
vantagem competitiva nessa competição
mundial de desenvolvimento econômico à
vontade nossa o sonho né de virar de
passar de terceiro mundo para o primeiro
mundo
então nossa vontade de jogar esse jogo é
tão forte que não sobra tempo pra gente
ver que esse jogo essa narrativa não
ou se há soluções milagrosas os países
ditos desenvolvidos na verdade é tempo
de crise enorme influência de países
livres essas que são necessárias para a
continuação dessa competição e que são
baseados no medo e na negação de outras
possibilidades que a gente vê a crise lá
fora e continua acreditando aquele
brasil na ilusão de que o
desenvolvimento baseado no lucro e no
consumo na exploração e na extração na
competitividade da competitividade no
individualismo vão trazer a felicidade
vai trazer felicidade e vai garantir o
crescimento econômico constante é também
interessante perceber que quando a gente
começa a levantar essas questões em
educação mais mais existir resistência
então eu comparo isso com a questão da
alimentação
se eu perguntar para os meus alunos se
eles preferem algodão doce
o bloco cru sem sal que é melhor para a
saúde deles
eles vão preferir o algodão doce se eu
perguntar pra ele ele prefere uma
educação que confirme as suas certezas e
que traga uma sensação de prazer ao
confirmar essa certeza uma educação e
questiona essa certeza e que abre mais
possibilidades mas que traga um
desconforto inicial temporário
meus alunos hoje tanto aqui quanto lá
estão preferindo o algodão doce
o conforto e isso é sinal de uma
sociedade orientada ao narcisismo que é
na minha opinião é o maior desafio da
educação hoje em dia eu volto para a
pergunta está a concluir como educar
para a complexidade à incerteza por ali
idade e um contexto de desigualdade a
educação moderna vai na direção oposta
como educar para que a gente possa
aprender com os erros e limites do milho
amarelo sem jogar ele fora e como se
educar para a criação de novas
realidades onde os mesmos erros não
sejam reproduzidos
muito obrigado